[Music]
this is something we've never had to
deal with in the history of the show
well those are the words backs our host
Chris Harrison could have said many
times during the 15-year run of the
franchise and Ali's here right now with
a look at some of the biggest
controversies to rock the show and there
have been many oh my gosh there have
been so many and I was actually that
clip that you saw I was a contestant on
the show when that happened I will never
forget it Nancy I mean things went
haywire people were frantic and that was
one of contestant with accused of
getting intimate with the producer what
was this physical relationship I'd like
to know all about it please in season 14
with Jake Pavelka Rosalynn Papa was
kicked off the show and the producer in
question fire it's all hype it's all
ratings I'm just telling my side the
story I'm telling the truth
she insists they were just friends
despite with the other contestants say
they witnessed and I saw I saw you guys
kissing on the stairs another shocker
from Jake's season happened after the
final rose his final pick Vienna accused
him of emotional abuse after the season
wrap please stop interrupting me
thing is when I got down on me again I
got interrupted for a less explosive
scandal but still costly to the
franchise happened in season 11 of The
Bachelorette just four weeks into the
season Kaitlyn Bristowe spoiled the
ending for fans by accidentally
snapchatting a picture of her in bed
with now fiancé Sean booth trust me that
was not on purpose and finally a bad
Chad Mexico meltdown Chad's trip to
bachelor Paradise lasted just 24 hours
he got sent home after getting drunk and
trying to fight his castmates
and host Chris Harrison you think this
is all like fun and games this is my
life you Chris Harrison
come at me oh my gosh Chris awaitin gets
thrown in the stickiest situations and
he always handles it so well and I know
Chris personally and he is such a good
guy so I want to say thank you Chris for
holding down the fort
[Music]
you